[Musica]
ogni affermazione utile sul futuro
dovrebbe inizialmente sembrarvi ridicola
se vi avessi detto qualche anno fa un
po' di anni fa che è una vecchia signora
tra la Giorgia l'Armenia con una sega
avrebbe
letteralmente devastato un paese per
un'intera giornata non mi avreste
creduto l'avesse trovato ridicolo
Cosa significa essere future Ready
essere pronti per il futuro inizia da
capire come funziona il futuro come sono
i tempi del futuro inizia dal capire che
non esiste un solo futuro Ma esistono
più futuri possibili più linee del
futuro che si possono aprire a seconda
degli eventi che avvengono nel tempo
molte ad essere gli eventi a influenzare
il futuro ciò che influenza il nostro
futuro è il modo di pensare delle
persone il mindset delle persone e ad
esempio all'interno delle nostre
organizzazioni esistono tre Minds
diversi il mindset della gestione dei
problemi di tutti i giorni quella del
management che necessariamente è un arco
temporale limitato mentre la curva più
lunga è quella dell'imprenditore che
deve vedere l'azienda più in là nel
tempo capire quali saranno i problemi
futuri prevenirli e infine il terzo
Orizzonte temporale che è quello più
visionario che deve vedere il futuro di
un'organizzazione più in là nel tempo e
ognuno di questi orizzonti temporali
anche uno spazio in cui opera c'è lo
spazio delle Operations tutto quello che
è legato alla produzione dei prodotti e
all'erogazione dei servizi ma c'è lo
spazio dell'organizzazione di tutto
quello che va organizzato intorno alla
produzione di questi prodotti e servizi
e lo spazio dell'imprenditore
e poi c'è la collocazione della nostra
organizzazione all'interno
dell'ecosistema in cui siamo la
dimensione sistemica
ma essere pronti per quale futuro ci
troviamo in un'epoca in cui la nostra
società sta vivendo momenti di
trasformazione profonda in cui stiamo
letteralmente rimodellando Il mondo
intorno a noi Ma cosa sta realmente
succedendo
le nostre società vivono all'interno di
un ciclo se vogliamo in diverse fasi noi
veniamo da una fase di certezze di
sicurezza sul futuro una fase in cui
l'economia È cresciuta in cui le
istituzioni che noi che hanno
rappresentato la nostra vita i nostri
stati ci hanno dato sicurezza sul futuro
ma nel momento attuale abbiamo iniziato
a percepire una frattura in qualche modo
di questi sistemi e iniziamo a percepire
incertezza sul futuro si parla di
resilienza Ma si va verso un'epoca in
cui ci sarà ancora più resistenza da
parte di vecchi sistemi che stanno in
qualche modo si stanno sgretolando e i
nuovi che sono in arrivo che li andranno
a sostituire e quindi si epoca dopo la
resistenza di questi di questi sistemi
si entra in un'epoca di rivoluzione
doveva arrivare realmente il cambiamento
fino ad arrivare alla a una rinascita a
un Rinascimento
in tutto questo ci sono sistemi che
collidono e sistemi vecchi sistemi che
collassano per dare spazio nuovi in
questo si generano le guerre purtroppo
ma abbiamo anche altri sistemi che sono
in qualche modo fratturati sono le
nostre catene biologiche il nostro
ecosistema del pianeta è fratturato e
tutto ciò genera nuovi pericoli non solo
a livello ambientale ma anche nuovi
virus
ci troviamo Nell'era delle incertezze lo
sappiamo e Nell'era delle incertezza
chiaramente l'ultima cosa da coltivare è
la certezza qualcosa da coltivare
nell'epoca dell'incertezza è piuttosto
la chiarezza nel capire cosa sta
cambiando e qualcosa sulla certezza la
chiarezza ve lo dico in questa slide la
certezza si esprime con delle regole la
chiarezza invece si esprime in storie la
certezza è darsi delle risposte la
chiarezza e porsi delle domande la
certezza non ha curiosità è già sicura
la chiarezza ha Molta curiosità
soprattutto delle idee diverse e ha
coraggio di affrontare idee diverse la
certezza infine
non sa cosa non sa e non le interessa
nemmeno molto saperlo mentre la
chiarezza sa che esiste molto che non sa
e tiene molto cuore il saperlo
quindi dimenticate le certezze e
sviluppate chiarezza
nel frattempo
Avete visto la rete sta galoppando e sta
cambiando moltissimo Siamo Nell'era
della rete immersiva della rete in 3D
della rete dovunque e siamo abituati a
un concetto di media che fa parte del
nostro spazio media possono essere degli
schermi dei device che fanno parte del
nostro spazio nel nostro ambiente ma nel
futuro della rete i media non sono più
una parte dello spazio in media
diventano lo spazio nel futuro della
rete ci muoviamo all'interno dei
contenuti tutta la rete è 3D ed è
intorno a noi sempre e costantemente ma
come sta succedendo questo
lo aveva capito già Negli anni cinquanta
paulbaran Paul Baren è uno dei fondatori
e le istituzioni anche uno dei Padri
Pionieri della rete internet e già Negli
anni cinquanta aveva capito che i nostri
sistemi informativi Sarebbero passati da
sistemi centralizzati a decentralizzati
a sistemi distribuiti Cosa significa
questi sistemi centralizzati hanno dato
origine ad esempio alle televisioni ai
primi mass media telefono Radio
e i sistemi decentralizzati hanno dato
origine alla rete internet alla rete
sociale ai social network
i sistemi distribuiti stanno dando
origine alla nuova rete immersiva e
realmente distribuita non fatti di nodi
appartenenti a paesi come abbiamo visto
prima è una rete dove lo spazio diventa
digitale dove lo spazio fisico Si
integra con lo spazio digitale e non è
solo fatta di visuals di immagini è
fatta di nuove entità nuove identità
abbiamo visto prima le daoli nft abbiamo
anche parlato di nuovi asset
criptovalute
ma soprattutto tutto questo mondo di
dati che prima era centralizzato poi
decentralizzato e ora è distribuito se
sta astraendo dal nostro territorio
fisico la territorialità dei dati non
appartiene più ai confini delle nostre
Nazioni nella rete distribuita i dati Si
astraggono dai confini nazionali quindi
Finalmente una rete senza confini
Alcuni la chiamano metaverso
ma il metaverso dietro di sé un
infrastruttura che sta evolvendo oggi
l'infrastruttura della nostra rete la
chiamiamo Internet of Things internet La
rete delle cose è nata connettendo cose
rendendole sempre più intelligenti e
questi oggetti sempre più intelligenti
stanno iniziando a interagire fra di
loro in maniera autonoma abbiamo veicoli
autonomi abbiamo fabbriche autonome
magazzini autonomi questa rete del
futuro è una rete che abbiamo chiamato
Internet of actions non più Internet of
Things perché questi oggetti statici
sono stati diventati sempre più
intelligenti fino ad essere in grado di
animarsi da soli e siamo In un'era di
nuovi superpoteri che ci dà questa rete
Iper tecnologica
nella rete delle azioni ci sono quattro
nuovi poteri fondamentali la capacità di
alterare la percezione umana
la capacità di Codificare ogni attività
dell'essere umano da ciò che facciamo
professionalmente alle nostre relazioni
sociali alle nostre interazioni
biologiche
ci darà la possibilità di manipolare la
materia e anche di animare interi spazi
oggetti e ambienti intorno a noi
E quindi che cosa come possiamo essere
più future ready
possiamo ridefinire
ridefinire cosa
ridefinire le nostre organizzazioni
istituzioni comunità passando da un
concetto di profit driven a un concetto
di purplestreven dove l'impatto il
significato dell'Opera è più importante
del profitto l'impatto sociale
Ma dobbiamo anche passare da un concetto
di esclusività nelle nostre relazioni è
un concetto di inclusività includere il
diverso
e dobbiamo passare da un concetto
energetico di semplice Potenza a Potenza
ma pulizia
dobbiamo poi reinventare
ridisegnare ogni entità e anche la
nostra identità nella nuova rete
dobbiamo ridisegnare i processi e la
nostra catena di valore
integrando i fondamenti di base della
sostenibilità in tutta la catena del
valore non solo in quello che facciamo
ma anche in quello che fanno i nostri
partner come ci relazioniamo con loro
dobbiamo rimodellare utilizzando la
tecnologia le nuove capacità che la
tecnologia ci dà questi nuovi
superpoteri devono far parte dei nostri
business model
e infine dobbiamo ricostruire
ricostruire diventando Climb positive
ovvero facendo tutto quello che è il
nostro potere per ridurre il nostro
impatto ambientale la nostra Carbon
footprint e dobbiamo utilizzare i
superpoteri che ci dà la tecnologia per
muoverci più velocemente fare di più con
meno perché esiste questa urgenza di
lavorare insieme con strumenti più
potenti per agire rapidamente e
risolvere i problemi di cui abbiamo
parlato oggi che sono parte integrante
del nostro futuro
Ma bisogna anche costruire sulla
diversità
Team che includono diversità modi
diversi di pensare
culture diverse soprattutto costruire su
nuovi valori e non più sul semplice
profitto
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]